eduardo only pitched one inning in a red
sox 6-2 victory over the yankees because
of the migraine that took over and
knocked him out so the swinging jays
they swing away and down he goes strike
three springer fans to begin the night
against eduardo that's such a key pitch
for him using his fastball but going
back to the changeup i mean you couldn't
ask for a better start i think for the
blue chase bases loaded and the best
hitter against the opponent's starting
pitcher
goes the other way and it's in high or
right field over there glove over in
front that'll score one for sure here
comes simeon around the third he's going
to score and beau buchet will get
stopped and now he's hung up and gets
back to third in time
the oscar and end is not wasting any
time that ball was misplayed out in
right field by renfro they got caught
off guard because it carried so well so
two outs now the oscar is still at
second base is kevin biggio he's got a
lot of room in left center
there's a base hit to right fit
redford's got a cannon for an arm here
comes to oscar to throw to the plate
offline calvin vigil picks up an rbi
well abuja is really aggressive renfro
has 11 outfit assists and they ran right
in his face with two outs and they've
scored three runs here in the top half
of the first going to face yunjin roo
for the third time this season 20th
start of the year for ryu he's got a 344
earned run average a 9-5 record
goes out to that high pitch and strikes
up
how are you two down in the inning first
strike out of the game springer struck
out on a change up his first startup one
of two strikeouts for rodriguez in the
first inning keep doing all the little
things to help you score runs
ground ball base hit that's going to
score reese maguire he's around third
and he comes in to score george springer
picks up the rbi single it's
four-nothing yeah you can't wait to get
in on it if you're george springer he
struck out and then the blue jays
had
six straight batters reach against
rodriguez george couldn't wait until
that lineup came back around now he's
going to hit join the hit parade with
that soft single back through the middle
gonna pick up the rbi that's a 17th rbi
to go along with nine home runs this is
only his 13th to bat against lefty
pitching this season
two and two swung on and missed the high
fastball gets him the strikeout second
strike out of the game for ryu
popped up middle of the diamond
simeon the second baseman makes the call
and ryu will strand a couple of base
runners so they're all filled up now for
simeon just back and forth
three-two pitch outside he walked him
well rodriguez walks in a run
as simeon will pick up an rbi espanol
got it started with the single and he
scores and that's going to be it
ground ball to third
back to second for one no throw to first
a run will come in
and abu jays will take a six-nothing
lead as springer scores
theater's choice for beshet picks up an
rbi his 69th
valdez and a 1-1
i fly right field to the corner retro
heading to the stands launches he caught
the ball
what a play by honoring
a sensational grab he paid the price for
it
actually i fear for the wall in that
case
tell you what that is not easy to do
sacrificing his body going into the wall
does not care don't doing anything to
make that play
excellent work well it's been an ugly
night but that was one beautiful play
those are going to get out of that
ballpark not taking anything away from
the young power in this lineup but
popped up down the line
giving chase for dugo reaching and he
caught it
the red sox with their corner
outfielders
playing can you top this
and an outstanding catch by verdugo into
the seats
blue jays are three for seven so far in
this game with runners in scoring
position first and second two outs
[Applause]
and if it's fair it's way gone
and it is a fair ball bloody guru
another first pitch home run
the only question is did it go
fair over that foul pole that was way
out of the ballpark no doubt about it
and guerrero circles the bases on a
three-run home run randle trying to get
into the act he asked on over three so
far he was robbed of an extra base hit
his last timer
it's this one on the line the left fear
that he is gotten into the app
as he drives home beau bechet
ten nothing blue jays randall gets an
rbi his 67th of the season and workman
has given up three straight hits espana
has scored a couple of runs he has
singled and walked
there's a blind drive that's going to
get down for a base hit one run is in
the score and they'll stop glitching at
third as espionage collects his second
hit of the ball game he's been on base
three times and he drives in a run that
gives him 11 for the season
to get a ball
as to
oscar waits on that curve ball and rips
it into left field and then vlady made
that play where he went first to third
that's how you play the game doesn't
matter what the score is
so
marcus simeon tags up on that fly ball
goes to third base gets his teammate an
rbi as tayo is enjoying his night with
his third hit
hit by a pitching ground at a second
for the red sox ever six four he tags
this one that ball is back there high
off the wall
vazquez is in the score and bobby will
slide into second with a double red sox
do get on the board tonight
it is 13-1 and he narrowly missed a home
run
called strike three
breaking ball called the strike
that might be a 13-1 strikeout right
there that ball was maybe off the plate
should solidify the hall of fame for
sure
oh strike three
he gets his second strikeout is chavis
looking at that fastball
one and two
calls strike three and that's the ball
game how about kirby snake striking out
three in the ninth in his second big
league game
but it was all about the hitters tonight
pat in boston